annonce des routes je sais que cela fait
mal et depuis mon pays je dis à ces
familles je suis profondément désolé des
excuses teintée d'incompréhension
c'est ainsi qu'alain ch megatli le père
du fugitif brian may gates qui s'est
exprimé à l'émission sixty menace
australia
visiblement ému le père est revenu sur
l'enfance difficile de son fils et sur
ces problèmes d'isolement mais il dit
attendre des preuves avant de le
qualifier de meurtrier en 15 mois et
change 1,3 je ne dirais pas que mon fils
est un meurtrier tant que je n'ai pas eu
de preuve
ok vous voulez que je vous dise là et
maintenant que mon fils a tué vos
concitoyens je ne le ferai pas parce que
je ne le peux pas j'ai perdu mon fils je
sais exactement ce que vous ressentez
mais pour la soeur de la victime china
disent ces excuses ne suffisent pas sur
facebook elle a répondu aux propos
d'alain chouet gaz qui par une longue
publication dans laquelle elle estime
qu'il aurait été plus approprié de
présenter de véritables excuses
la chasse à l'homme pour retrouver
brioche meygal ce qui est son présumé
complice camatte lahoud soupçonné
d'avoir assassiné trois personnes en
colombie britannique a tenu le canada en
haleine pendant deux semaines
leurs corps ont été retrouvés mercredi
dans une forêt non loin de guy l'homme
dans le manitoba
une autopsie a été effectuée ces
résultats seront connus demain ici à ce
mitraillage radio canada montréal